long time
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day it is
Wednesday in a cluttered congested and
overpopulated in New York this week more
than ever I am feeling the downsides of
living in this godforsaken city and you
know what I had a thought today how
grateful I am that Amazon didn't end up
moving here oh well of course and then
it was like very controversial cuz it
would been great for the economy and
create a lot of jobs but like we
literally can't handle it one week a
year is the UN General Assembly where
diplomats from all around the world fly
in to New York to have the assembly at
the US and assemble to assemble I don't
know what they do but Greta Sundberg
gave a speech and that's literally all
I've heard like it's literally the most
useless week it's like these people
whose jobs is literally like to do
nothing get together to do it together
and they cause so much traffic they
close every Street every single tip of
every country has at least four SUVs
driving them around with two police
escorts it's pandemonium you cannot move
in the city it's so crazy it is one of
the week today is a day for Cleveland
like we're moving it's a Cleveland week
and also we need to start planning
better and just like take a vacation
this week because we should have done
podcast episodes from home because it's
and by the way like the whole city I
like I went into a meeting yesterday in
Midtown which is like the most affected
area and ever in the office was like
how'd you get here like it's literally a
war zone I've just been walking
everywhere because there's no start and
so now I just like have a backpack on
all day and sneakers like when I got
home I change it and so I can just walk
everywhere or such like a I'm so
industrious but man I came to your house
yesterday I mean obviously walked um I
think it's the way to go I've been
walking everywhere basically probably
walking it's not physically possible to
walk here but I wish that I could yeah
also what boots are made for walking
this is a week for moving to Cleveland
but it's also a week where you like you
walk aggressively and like you shove
tourists you know comedian Margo it took
us three hours to get home from Newark
Airport we got back from New Jersey into
the city 45 minutes to get from just the
tunnel to our houses was over an hour
and a half I got out and walked with my
suitcase which is the worst and I was
walking through the most touristy area
cuz we got stuck in Times Square I was
[ __ ] literally like side shoving a
million tourists like if you're in my
guy
that is your problem like this is not a
week for tourists to come tour no this
managing being a tourist and like this
is your first time coming to New York
and this is the week you happen to
choose and you probably think this it I
mean the city's crazy and it's you know
hustle and bustle but you probably think
it's an today yeah oh my god not
enjoyable I I'm I'm just so angry this
morning like just planning I've been
planning my life in my week around
knowing that there's traffic so I'm
really not making plans more than like
20 blocks away from me especially during
peak hours during peak out like 5 to 7
I'm home but also the hour like 9 to 10
yeah but that's what you have to get get
to work yeah it's it's I mean oh my look
and how many overs it took for me cuz I
have to get one go in a certain way in
order to get here I think I literally
checked like my bank account because he
charges you every time that you have an
uber but then they put it back on your
card maybe over 20 times just to get one
going the right way is so crazy
I literally yesterday made all my
meetings calls like I had to work from
home it's so crazy it's so crazy also
yesterday we did a patreon episode we s
we do a full dear toasters episode a lot
of interesting quandary x' lots of
mediocre advice i think you guys will
enjoy yeah it was actually we got looks
such we did a patreon specific dear
toasters and we got submissions just for
the patron episode I guess people didn't
want to submit to the podcast because
it's like a little public and we got
such crazier ones like I was actually
really surprised I guess the the idea of
the episode being behind a paywall made
people like open up more because it's
not as public and it was a great episode
so if you want to head to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast we did
that yesterday in addition to having
like a bunch of hits yesterday I had the
biggest pick something and I had the
biggest pick yesterday - I was about to
say speaking of quand Ruiz I yesterday I
offended some people with what I said on
the show about movie theaters and there
was a lot of talk about it and the
people really want you to apologize and
people really want me to apologize and I
thought about this like I've had
conversations in my head for the past 24
hours and I'm not going to apologize for
what I said because people are making it
so much more than it is and I don't want
to condone doing that and like people
are inferring from what I said like so
many other like awful like class
interpretation I meant and I didn't mean
anything more or less than what I said
so I'm not going to apologize
and endorse what you guys are saying I
meant well this is its it's the
interpretations I think that people are
being offended by and I got a lot of
messages of people like who were really
upset by it and then they messaged me
like I'm sorry I read the stuff in the
group first and then watch the episode
and thought that the group's reaction
was like a misinterpretation and I think
a lot of people who are speaking on it
didn't even listen to it totally because
they just heard Jackie say this thing
which is someone paraphrasing for you
and inferring which is not actually what
you meant
no and like the statement itself I'm not
gonna explain my mics I think the people
who are waiting for an apology
definitely don't want to hear me
reiterate um it's not like my finest
statement I you know I'm not gonna put
it as my yearbook quote but like that's
what this show is we say what we think
we say how we feel this was a feeling I
had a few years ago I was sharing with
the class and I think by apologizing for
it will you know it doesn't set a good
precedent for this show like we're
allowed to just say how we feel
run and not apologize for every small
single thing otherwise I don't feel
empowered to just speak my mind and then
at the same time many times I've said
something on the show that I deeply
regretted I'm sure if they had explained
to me like why it was hurtful and I
didn't think of it in the moment and
then after speaking with people like I
understand how that can be hurtful and
always whenever someone explains
something to me and I agree with them
and I do see how my words were wrong I
am always very happy to apologize
Nietzsche and I think that if we just
started like randomly apologize it takes
a like when I apologize I try to be a
woman of my word when I apologize I mean
it and I'm truly deeply sorry if I start
apologizing for things just because
people want me to it takes away from all
of my past apologies and all of my
inevitable future apologies because we
talk over an hour every day on the show
there's gonna be something that people
don't agree with and by the way I think
that's good
we shooters we shouldn't all agree all
the time you guys shouldn't agree with
every single thing that we say and yeah
bring it up in a group the way that
thread like went was like all the
different tangents and like inferences
that people made I wasn't totally your
butt but voicing your opinion I'm so
here for though I don't think this dish
show the group should ever become like
an echo chamber where you have to agree
with every single thing that we say and
that also means that we don't have to
apologize for everything thing every
single thing that we
and so for this one I'm not apologizing
because I think that it will it takes
away from all the apologies that I mean
and not only that people are more
everyone is allowed to disagree with
everyone but at the end of the day you
were stating how you felt yeah like in
this current as a matter of fact and you
weren't saying that everyone should feel
this way you're dissing your experience
with going the movies in the past few
years because it has become like such an
unsafe space at the ends of the day
that's your feeling and regardless of
whether people think it's valid you are
entitled to your opinion you're not
shoving your opinion on anyone else it's
the way that you feel and that's and
that's that that's that and I know it's
um even the people who didn't like you
know make inferences were just in saying
that they were upset that I was so
flippant about such a serious subject
and again like I think it's important on
the show that we reserve the right to do
that that's how a lot of people that's
how we get through things that are
difficult to talk about it's just you
know like shedding a little light and a
little laughter on the subject and like
I think it's important that we do that
that's what this show is about there are
enough shows out there that will handle
serious matters very seriously and you
can get that experience somewhere else
not a lot of people do what we do and I
I like what we do and I like how we I
and when I don't I will apologize but
this isn't one of those times it's okay
to laugh about things that make you sad
and it's okay to not agree with what
what someone says but how you disagree
with them is what's more important like
some of the things you can disagree the
civil discourse I know it's like a a new
concept in America but you can disagree
with someone and still be friends with
them like it's so crazy how it's so
extreme so I just I just want everyone
to keep in mind like if you were if you
really were so offended like it brought
you to tears let's say and if that is
the case I feel so bad that I made you
feel bad
uh and I'm sorry for that but I know
that's not an apology but that's never
what we're trying to do where it's a
show to keep that in mind
literally the point of this show is
never to be anything other than happy
and light and fun there is enough
tragedy going on in the world we do not
need to contribute to that so I think
it's important for everyone to always
keep in mind the important the intention
of this show is never ever ever ever to
upset anyone and if by some chance that
does happen please keep in mind that
that's just not in our attentions and
there's a way to communicate you know
like if you and people when I've said
something in tope thought it was totally
innocent in someone
Munich ated to me in a respectful way
about how incredibly stupid it was what
I said or ignorant like thank you that's
helpful
no and I have pits all the time about
things that I say on the show and
sometimes someone will mention and I'm
like yeah no I [ __ ] up and I'm so
sorry and I have and I mean it but
sometimes like I'm not seeing what
you're seeing and that's fine too that's
fine too but I can't stress enough civil
discourse ladies and gentleman's rights
good stuff right it's all good we are
going to deliver the Fast Five but I
wanted to share an update a story we
shared yesterday about Richard Robert
Smith who was that billionaire who paid
off everyone's dad I actually got a DM
from a toaster who had some good tea and
it's not bad it's just interesting tea
on Robert Smith Robert Smith owns an
equity firm called Vista that owns a
bunch of companies and this Gerald what
this girl owns what I mean works for one
of those company okay he's the second
richest african-american in the u.s.
behind Oprah he it's super cool that he
paid off all the student loan debt but
it was for an all-boys school whatever
that's where they asked him to speak
that is where they asked you to speak
but that's also interesting that they
left that out yeah no I know what's also
interesting I kept on trying to get more
information on Morehouse College and no
I did not see that anywhere she all says
this is the most important part all the
wives of the executives at Vista got
Hermes bags for Christmas did you hear
that
no all there they all got Hermes extra
Christmas and the CEO of her company got
a Bentley oh my god he knows how to live
just wanted to share the tea he loved
the show like that's what if you were a
rich person yeah like you would do know
1000% way to say spend money and let's
like enemies bag is a perfect gift cuz
obviously it's like highly coveted but
like not everyone wants one but you can
sell it and just get cash and it's also
give you cash it's a great gift also
because it was for the wives of
executives I mean I guess that's
assuming that all the executives are men
but whatever but ok we're gay I guess
but yeah or like maybe you have a female
executive and you know husband one
summers yeah right no I'm just saying
like it's actually a nice gift because
I'm sure you know as executives they
work a lot and like the wives deserve
something too ok also he went to
Morehouse oh ok so that actually makes
sense makes a lot it was such a big deal
that it was an all-boys school that's
where they asked him to speak like yeah
ask him
yeah like the twins us now all these
colleges are gonna be totally Wow that's
pretty cool yeah I just thought that was
interesting update from yesterday that I
wanted to share well thank you for that
update um what else happened to me last
night that I want to share I'm like just
like an endless pit of hunger like my
stomach it's starting to - how hungry I
am because Ben is out of town and for
some reason like Ben is my structure
like when Betty gets home eat dinner and
it was like 8 o'clock already and he
didn't II and I'm like am I really gonna
order food now like you're not supposed
to eat after 8:00 send by 11 o'clock I
had to get ice cream like it was just so
stupid it was really like a poorly
managed day for me I'm sorry I'm trying
to intermittent fasting again because
I've been hearing like new good things
so I'm just I'm hungry but I have a
reason to be yeah I'm just so hungry all
the time and you know what I'm tired of
being hungry and every now and then when
I'm trying to like be healthy and like
not eat as poorly I'm so hungry I'm like
you know what [ __ ] this I can just can
eat what I want and whenever I'm like
eating what I want then like just being
in poor health I'm still hungry like
that feeling doesn't go away no it
doesn't and it's also like a mint it's a
state of mind you know right now it's a
physicality for sure but generally
speaking like you're probably not that
hungry I agree you're just bored yeah
and you just want to eat because it's
the best thing to do we have Stephanie
Holman on the show today from the Real
Housewives of Dallas we're very excited
so we are gonna get through the story so
we can talk to her she is just chefs
kiss like she's everything I'm really
excited to talk to her she was on the
breath but I wasn't there she was on the
breath but she's sky did OH like so we
never actually have met her no and so
although she's been on the show before
like she kind of hasn't yeah yeah so I'm
really really excited I got my boots on
for her like just want to respect you
know so let me check my watch is it um
yeah it's time it's time yeah [ __ ] it's
time okay it is time it is time it's
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and it
is it's time but you know part of my job
on this show is to rake in the dollars
and it would be absolutely heartbreaking
if I didn't let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by noon
getting in shape isn't about losing
weight it's about learning healthier
habits and feeling better about yourself
whether that's more stamina to keep up
with your busy life finally getting into
those gold jeans being more in tune with
your body's needs or
to sing more self-care what if you could
use one program for all your health and
weight loss needs no more hunting for
training apps or workouts or calorie
trackers and meal plans you can add a
goal specialist to your community of
members to keep you motivated and
accountable and it's like a workout
bestie specific goals you want to
achieve
so basically numa's basically like the
toast it's an online community people
who all have the same goal they they
want to get better self-care they want
to feel more confident and clothing feel
like they have more energy and just get
that overall glow it's super easy and
convenient because of the app it can
help you break bad habits
I just think having that accountability
factor on your phone is what helped me
the most like I just knew that that app
was staring at me and if I didn't like
contribute and I didn't stay in line
like it would it would just sit there
staring and everything would fall apart
it's a habit changing solution but it
understands that like not every day is
gonna be your best day and it's like
okay to go off track as long as you get
back on you could chat with your goal
specialist and the name community to get
and give help to people going through
the same thing it helps your user it
helps the users learn and develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses it's based in
psychology they teach you why you do the
things you do and in arms you with the
tools to break the bad habits to replace
them like ordering ice cream at 11
o'clock last night you don't have to
change everything in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon calm / toast that's N oom
calm / toast what do you have to lose
visit new home / toast to start your
trial today that's Noom calm / toast the
late last weight loss program you'll
ever need love it sanim look amazing do
it okay first up a little sad news shark
tank star Kevin O'Leary's wife has been
charged in the fatal crash the wife of
shark tank star Kevin O'Leary has been
charged in connection with the fatal
boat crash last month on a Canadian Lake
according to reports linda O'Leary 56
was charged with careless operation of a
vessel stemming from the August 24th
collision on Lake jokes Joseph in
Ontario that killed two passengers of
another vessel CTV News reported on
Tuesday she was allegedly piloting the
boat when it slammed into a larger 13
person vessel returning to a lake
cottage just before midnight a New York
man who was driving the other boat was
also charged in connection with the
incident the driver Richard Roe was
charged with failing to exhibit
unlike the outlet reported Gary pull -
64 of Florida was struck in the head and
killed instantly in the collision
officials said another passenger Suzanne
britto was brought to the hospital where
she later succumbed to her injuries so
sad that two people died there seems to
be this overwhelming consensus among
people that his wife is taking the fall
for him like it's it's baseless there's
no proof but people just genuinely think
because he was drinking and she wasn't
that like she took the fall for him
because if she gets charged it's much
less likely that she'll go to prison
because she wasn't drinking yeah and
there was a head like situation yeah
this is just so sad and bad I saw a
little bit of rumors that but it's
founded nothing but it makes a lot of
sense yeah um I don't know this this is
crazy this is crazy like do you think
well the new season of shark tank
actually premieres this week it's
already filmed so like what effect I
just like when something like this
happens like how does it affect your day
job you know and what I think about is
like Rory Laughlin who was fired for
like just being on trial for something
and and and no one died and so it's like
but also it's Kevin's wife so you're not
early but you know you're not held
accountable for the actions of your wife
I guess like it should affect your jobs
William each Macy's job in effect in no
shameless everyone's I actually finished
shameless last night a to watch like
everyone's dropping out like do you
think if he had been charged like with
his wife I mean uh felissa Familia major
may say yeah if he had been charged with
his wife like just like how Massimo and
where do you think he would have been
fired from shameless I don't know I was
like no it sounds like no because you
know why his characters like such a
degenerate he's like a deadbeat dad an
alcoholic drug addict that like honestly
this is kind of on brand for him oh yeah
I mean I guess it's like a hallmark and
Felicity Huffman hasn't necessarily been
fired for many because she wasn't
actively working okay she wasn't on a
show she's done movies like homework is
a family Network I understand why they
wouldn't want to be tied to that but
like show times he's like they show
titties on show time you know that yeah
yeah I actually don't think he would
have been fired but if he went to jail
maybe but ABCs
family network but you know what NBC
where does it air show time shark tank
Oh ABC yeah yeah but with with William H
Macy I don't think he would have been
fired one because Emmy Rossum just
stepped down from the show as did can't
murder what's his name who's dating
Peyton list Cameron Moynihan yeah so
like the show was really losing its like
core family members and Frank is now
really the star of the show like he
always was but like I mean you're
awesome was like kind of there too but
he he's the star and I don't think they
would really care like it's not like
he's this you know good father a show
yeah I know but I know what she didn't
matter but like to me as a viewer like I
couldn't care less
yeah I know so he wasn't charged she
wasn't responding to the emails and the
crime that Felicity committed was like
less severe than right now so yeah they
really managed to get out completely
unscathed not completely she's going to
jail for 14 days I know but like in in
if you look at it big picture of how bad
it could have been he wasn't charged
she's only going to jail for 14 days and
I was watching Knightley pop where they
said she's probably going to have to go
to jail a certain amount of distance
from where you were sentenced and
there's like a prison for like you know
rich people that she requested to go to
it's like they had yoga they have camp
but like it's really it's not and you
only have to serve if you're on good
good behavior like 85% of your sentence
so I don't know what 85% of 14 is but
she could end up spending like only ten
days in prison and if you look at it
from just like an octave Optus
perspective how bad it could have been
to what it actually is gonna be it's
like they really got out clean oh I
disagree I think the crime of they spent
fifteen thousand dollars for one kid and
then they didn't do it again because
they obviously realized that they did
something wrong and that meaning jail
time I think that it's actually a huge
punishment and this is like they
couldn't have gotten anything more than
that so this is really like the worst
that it could be I don't know I think
that I give the Lauri Lachlan mine up
with 14 days that would be like you know
what it's not so bad she committed a
major crime yeah but at the same time
like what the judge said was like this
this needs to be made an example out of
like it's like the it's the pinnacle of
like privilege and the judge was like
regardless of like yes she didn't kill
anyone like if you think about it but
but knowing that like as a celebrity you
get special treatment like I don't think
14 days in prison is like really that
of a deal look I think this is a I think
the reason is a big deal I think this is
a fair punishment like I think the
punishment actually does fit the crime
oh I don't know 15 grand to get your kid
into school and then you didn't do it
again like the fact that yeah that teen
grand but it's also like it's they were
you were writing it off as like a
charity donation that is technically tax
evasion because you don't pay taxes on
charity deductions like but it's it's a
15 grand deduction yes so happens it's
so the the total bill of taxes that they
saved isn't that also I think in like
the grand scheme of the justice system
it's almost a light sentence like now
people are pulling up examples of like
people who aren't rich and famous you
know that agree we like lied about where
their kids live so they could go to a
better school zone and are spending five
years in prison yeah you know and that's
a whole other issue I think in the
[ __ ] up climate of our you know broken
judicial system this seems fair she's
there when you compare it to other
things but on its own it seems extreme
but again she can handle it she can
handle it yeah but I don't know if I'm
Laurie Lachlan I'm shaking in my boots
yeah totally this does not bode well
because people were wondering if the two
of them would ever even get jail time at
all so if the one who did lesser you
guys get in jail time it's not it's not
gonna be good okay so back to Kevin
O'Leary's why yes this is bad yes two
people have passed yeah it's bad it's
bad and the shadiness is also confusing
I think it's it's bad yeah and like I
think it's like gonna get gonna get into
the shark tank oh you think just might
oh nothing I don't know what the right
thing to do is I don't make the
decisions but like this is bad yeah and
shark tank is like a family show it was
true his name is mr. wonderful yeah and
by the way like people are like loving
the joke this is not so wonderful oh god
yeah like you can't do anything at these
days without like people talking about
in your face you know yeah but the
headlights on the victims boat were so
like I don't know they're obviously
there has to be a trial yeah innocent
until we need to go to a trial ones
um no that's jury duty no you could sit
it's open to the public
yeah it's so boring is it yeah it's not
like low moaner
no it's me no they just like get to the
interesting parts okay next up Brad Pitt
is dating designer and holistic healer
sorry khalsa you guys Brad Pitt has a
new lady in his life and it is not
Kourtney Kardashian very upsetting nor
is it Chloe but you know what's
interesting is this the type of girl
that he's dating was like this holistic
you know crystal healer makes me think
that actually Kourtney Kardashian might
have been his type because she's very
like holistic organic no I she is his
type but this might even confirm for me
that like they were doing something a
hundred percent the actor 55 is dating
jewelry designer and holistic healer
Saud Hari Khalsa a source exclusively or
Veals in the new issue of Us Weekly
according to the salt the source Khalsa
50 is earthy and much more loan
maintenance than the women he's been
with in the past
she's very strong as the insider has a
beautiful mind that's what he's
attracted to honestly sounds like the
insider is sitar II because like who
describes someone as having a great mind
oh she was embarrassing photo of them
together where they don't look like a
cup no ever does not look incriminating
at all they look like two people who are
sitting next to each other at a
restaurant like they might not even be
at the same reservation the photos from
2018 is from a year ago so maybe they
just like met yeah they met connected
they spent the evening sitting side by
side laughing and talking intimately
yeah I'm gonna take this with a grain of
salt I don't know if US Weekly getting
an exclusive about Brad Pitt isn't
necessarily the most reliable but I'm
open to it you know I'll keep this in
the back of my mind but in my mind he's
still single upon further investigation
this source is sad hari yeah she [ __ ]
for at least a story about herself and
where do you think she got they got the
picture from her phone yeah no I I'm
officially not buying it and I'm back on
the Kourtney and Brad [ __ ] yeah the the
the insiders information it's like a
little too specific like it sounds like
it was literally written by a crystal
healer she's a great mind strong brain
like yeah that is what a crystal healer
and Hollis
would say yeah so I shouldn't like
promoting her jewelry collection you
know she should have been more specific
like if she wanted us to know that it
was written in like the third person
quote-unquote she should have been like
yeah [ __ ] Satori [ __ ] rocks and
then I'd be like this definitely wasn't
written by Satori yeah or be like you
know they're having trouble integrating
their lives together but they're
hell-bent on making it work yeah
something like a negative with a
positive yeah so it looks like he's
still dating Kourtney Kardashian that's
the official word from the morning toast
yeah well let's see what happens next
Monday after Sunday service you know
look one of the news publications have
to say that yeah and maybe like maybe um
maybe Brad put this out so that like
Kourtney would get a little bit more
serious about him even though I don't
think if Brad and Kourtney are actually
dating like I don't think the one that
needs to get serious is Kourtney like
she knows a good man when she sees it
and Brad is actually that's actually
like not what yeah no she didn't know
Scott and to be honest actually she was
a good woman
I ship him and Chloe actually a lot more
I know she's such like a fun free spirit
yeah but I just don't think it would
work like I think actually
vibe wise Brad and Kourtney like are on
the same wavelength like you know like
it into place in their lives they
actually look to be a little bit more
compatible but or spirit wise I think
Brad Pitt could really use a Khloe
Kardashian in his life yeah oh of course
she's just such a free spirit right who
she is if a spirit
she loves lyrics and she gets her ears
parse at the gallery yeah it's true okay
next story to me more has Gemma sorry
I think it's Tim it's to me and normally
I would just say dummy but I like saying
to me more okay Jenna's released a book
and she is taken over the headlines with
some of the things she sent you and some
of the things she's saying other people
are saying are not true so Demi Moore
says she that she relaxed after Ashton
Kutcher allegedly said that alcohol
alcohol ISM quote wasn't a real thing oh
no to me Moore was on a romantic
vacation with her ex-husband Ashton
Kutcher when she broke her sobriety of
nearly 20 years
quote Ashton was enjoying a glass of
good red wine
and he said I don't know if alcoholism
is a real thing I think it's all about
moderation she writes in quotes that
she's quoting him look she's
paraphrasing yeah no she direct quoted
him remember a direct quote yeah from 20
years ago yeah and it wasn't 20 years
ago but whatever it was well yeah she
maybe she kept a journal maybe okay a
planner yeah where she wrote out the
mean quotes of the day mean things my
husband said to me today she writes in
her tell-all book inside out I wanted to
be that girl the girl who could have a
glass of wine at dinner or do a tequila
shot at a party in my mind
Ashton wanted that too so I tried to
become that a fun normal girl more 56
continued I didn't think quote this is a
kid in his 20s who has no idea what he's
talking about yeah I think quote I have
nearly two decades of sobriety under my
belt and that's a huge accomplishment
instead I cast about for justifications
that night she had a beer from the
minibar hotel hotel minibar oh my god
that is so sad like what an incredibly
dumb thing to say I kind of know what he
means like that's what we talk about
sometimes like with countess LuAnn it's
like she because she got arrested is
being treated like she is an alcoholic
when in reality I don't think she's an
alcoholic I just think she literally
cannot she's like a bad drunk yeah and
for her it definitely is a an aspect of
moderation but alcoholism is definitely
a very real thing and there are people
who can't moderate and that's why they
are alcoholics yeah so that's really sad
and the fact that she broke her sobriety
like on a beer is even sadder yeah she
detailed her spiral back into addiction
blaming herself for losing a pregnancy
because of her drinking and the collapse
of her relationship with Kutcher with
whom she was married from 2005 to 2013
she's also she's talking a lot about her
relationship with him in this book
because it was so crazy like when I was
when it was happening I didn't realize
that it was a big deal but like now I
realize because then really know who
Demi Moore was I was saying who Ashton
Kutcher was from Punk'd but I didn't
know who who Demi Moore was and now like
as an adult who understands more of like
the Hollywood landscape I realized these
two getting married for a long time is
really weird ya know it's crazy and now
that he's married to Mila Kunis and he
has this like whole family it's crazy to
think that he had this whole other life
like in recent memory yeah that was very
public yeah but so he's obviously pissed
and he tweeted the other night
especially because I like he's
it's for a million reasons but he's
really has a great image like he does a
lot of charity work like everyone loves
him in Mila like they always go on LA on
Shark Tank yeah he's like an investor
who is a plus like he's always sharing
good charity videos like I just think
this is a huge dent in an image he has
really worked hard to to create so he
tweeted quote I was about to push the
button on a really snarky tweet then I
saw my son daughter and wife and I
deleted it life is good
yeah I think that's wise I think that's
why she's also making claims just about
their relationship and him having three
sons and her feeling that like just a
lot of scandalous stuff that may or may
not be true she also talked about how
she took Jon Cryer's virginity and then
heat we didn't know I lost my virginity
in high school but thanks but but he
probably thought I'd lost my virginity
because I was so bad at sex oh that's
hilarious but it's just not good because
now it looks like her book is full of
falsity yeah and I don't think when it
when it comes to things she said about
her marriage like I don't think she's
lying because I think everything in
there when it comes to a marriage it's
like what she perceived as her truth
like there really are two sides to every
story and they're all true like you and
I could have an interaction and recount
it completely differently and neither
one of us are lying no I agree it's
really just like how we perceived it so
I don't think she's lying and I don't
think he's probably lying and wanting to
deny what she's saying I just think it's
really like perception is everything I
agree and I think actually was he
tweeted was perfect because it's like
him saying I did not everything no and
like not everything that she's saying is
my version of the truth either I'm in a
good enough place that it's not gonna
bog me down and I'm not gonna like you
know my camp isn't like right running
around trying to like get ray to say it
and it's crazy that this book is just
like really making a big splash you know
when if you gonna have to get would you
would ask me like who's Hello is gonna
be all over the headlines like I
wouldn't have said to me more no totally
like she's really very low-key yeah
except you remember kind of recently
like she was she was away on vacation
and like someone died in her pool yeah
yeah that was a [ __ ] weird story yeah
there's there's a lot of that honestly I
might read the book you know it sounds
good it does actually I meant to tell
you I was um I've been taking around
Howard Stern's book with me because you
rave so much about it and I was too
heavy to take her oh my god Jackie
literally ruined my bag and it's such a
big
book it's so big and you read it so fast
and like I really don't like to read but
I'm loving it
you're reading it yes I read it all the
entire trend is it true yes the entire
trip I think you read it okay I read it
and so it's basically like he's segments
there was like a million chapters and
they're all interviews with different
celebrities and I did skip some like
Anderson Cooper I think there was maybe
like one that I skipped no I skipped
Anderson Cooper I also was about to skip
Bill Murray and then I'm so glad that I
didn't because I'm much shocked at how
normal he is like you think he's like
this crazy got no he's just like very
normal and it's such a good book
obviously like getting to know
celebrities is like the best part
because I'm obsessed with pop culture
but Howard is such a stand-up guy and he
talked so much about like him going to
therapy and how it helped him so much
because he used to be like this evil
jealous person and when he was talking
about like his jealousy like I totally
related to it like it's he's like it's
such a terrible way to live like when
people around you like good things
happen for them and like you want to be
happy but like you really can you feel
you physically can't because you're so
jealous and you feel like it should be
happening to you and like I was
embarrassed reading it because I'm like
that's literally how I feel whenever
like like someone totally unrelated to
me that gets like a good thing I'm like
that should be me like it's such an
awful way to live in like and I knew
that about myself but then like hearing
that like someone else littering and the
exact same feeling was like kind of
eye-opening and I was like damn I mean
he said like when he stopped feeling
that way it's like this huge weight
lifted off of him and he did that by
going to therapy and I'm like damn like
I need that weight lifted off of me like
it's a terrible way to live yeah I think
there's a lot in there that you can
relate to yeah um and I look forward to
hearing your additional thoughts I'm
really looking joying it I don't want to
finish it like I like reading it like
whenever I need a book not like the good
news is like when I finished it I just
felt better cuz I was like oh now I can
just go listen to Howard Stern knowing
all this stuff of me yeah
whereas when I was just like an
uneducated person like when I get know
him I didn't understand like Bob a bit
and they've always said like I want to
go on Howard Stern but like after
reading the books I don't know if I
would ever really go no you have to if
you ever got that opportunity you have
to commit you have to okay
so thanks for the recommendation no
problem I don't recommend like dad
especially not know you don't know you
job especially to me
I'm not gonna waste your time on reading
written word if it ain't good okay next
story craziness anheuser-busch to have
quote no further association with Carson
King over social media posts okay so all
week a story has been coming out like a
really sweet story in the sports world
so we didn't really cover it and I
didn't really hear about it until today
where there's this guy Carson King he
like held up a sign on ESPN in the
audience saying like needs money for his
up make money from beer like one in a
bush site plays my Benbow yeah he was
looking to raise $25 like within out he
got it supposed to be like cute and
kitschy make a cute viral thing within
like hours he had $600 and then he
started raising so much money and he
immediately called his family I was like
I'm goning all this money to like the
Iowa children's wing Hospital research
so it just became this really filled a
thing all these different brands got on
board and then once he announced that he
was gonna be donating it he got even
more more money I think he's up to like
1.3 million yeah and I stood by the fact
that he was gonna donate it all and Bush
light and then mow both said that they
would match whatever he raises a lot of
other corporate sponsors got on board
but as of this morning an Heiser Bush
announced Tuesday that it will cut ties
with Carson King the Iowa State band who
has raised over 1 million dollars for
the University of Iowa's Ted family
Children's Hospital over multiple
offensive social media posts he made
King held the press conference Tuesday
to discuss a controversial post he said
a reporter with the Des Moines Register
called attention to an offensive social
media post he made when he was 16 years
old
quote 8 years ago when I was a sophomore
in high school I made some social media
posts with my friends that quoted and
referenced the show tosh point-o one of
those posts was brought to my attention
by a member of the media today the Des
Moines Register has been nothing but
kind and all their coverage and I
appreciate the reporter pointing out the
post to me I want everyone to understand
that this was my decision to publicly
address the posts and apologize I
believe that it's the right thing to do
and then in statement anheuser-busch
said Carson King had multiple social
media posts that do not align with our
values as a brand or as a company and we
will have no further association with
him we are honoring our commitment by
donating more than three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to the University
of Iowa Hospitals and Clinics and in his
statement he also went on to say like
when which I thought I really related
she was like when when I was
this tweet like it was I had to be
reminded that I even said that like I
didn't even remember ever writing that
and I think that we should now like I
choose to live my life by this tweet
that I wrote three years ago and it was
talking about how like you know hatred
and racism is a learning behavior that
needs to be unloaded like he's obviously
very woke and his tweet from three years
ago I was incredibly different from his
tweet from six years ago eight eight
years ago and this story is just like so
disappointing like it's really like a
culmination and it oh I'm sorry and the
best part of this whole story is that
the person who wrote the article for the
Des Moines Register and really did like
a quote-unquote background check to find
these tweets obviously like sports fans
went after him and found literally some
like of all the tweets I've ever seen
like some of the worst like n-word
f-word like awful awful awful so he is
more of than likely gonna be fired by
the Des Moines Register and he who
scoundrel DUP one screenshot actually
had like four or five or six of his own
um and I think it's more recent history
but this this whole scenario like gave
me the biggest pin like this is the
exact problem with canceled culture like
negates positivity and in one sales
sweep we demonstrate what is right and
wrong with the world
yeah like these wonderful moments that
like go viral and like are meant to be
just sweet and just meant to be good and
now it's like Mar down by all of this
stuff from like so long ago and I just I
don't know why someone would like seek
out and the posts of his have not been
released
right they paraphrased it in the
register article and then I tried to
find them on Twitter and I can't find
that yes so I don't even know exactly
what it was that he said and so but
let's just go with offensive post I
don't know it was bad it was it was a
tosh point-o reference about like a joke
comparing like african-american women to
gorillas like it was not good no it's
not no it's awful offensive is offensive
and and and this is not good I just like
like the guy the the journalist who who
wrote it he one of his tweets was like
don't make me convert you to a Jew I
mean it's just so rich you know it's
it's a that's just like the hypocrisy
it's like everyone makes mistakes and
everyone can change
and do I think that Carson King in
present moment is racist no do I think
that he made a mistake yes do we think
he should be punished for one thing he
said eight years ago absolutely not do I
think the children of the Iowas Hospital
should be punished for what he's did
eight years ago
no like everyone's still gonna give the
money but obviously like it's tainted
it's over the campaign is over there
could have been more money to be raised
but it's not gonna happen
um and I just think like and again this
might not be a popular opinion simply
because we have been on the side of the
tweets and like when when you read
something that someone says you
automatically assume that's how they
feel yeah and knowing firsthand that
that's 100% not like things that I
tweeted eight ten years ago like are
absolutely no reflection of the person
that I am today and I know that but it's
hard for someone else to know that
someone else sees oh this is what they
really think yeah so I totally
understand why someone would be up in
arms and really think that Carson King
is this person and what he said eight
years ago is who he is but as someone
who was you know um who was like held
responsible for what they said eight
years ago and people really thought
that's how I feel I know firsthand like
that is more than likely not the case
yeah and also what the video was Tosh
point now is even canceled at these are
his works he's very controversial oh is
he I think he does I remember when like
everyone used to watch that show and I I
don't I never got into it I hate I
always get him confused with them Dane
Cook
Abid you look alike especially good call
okay thank you but he would just like
say crazy stuff I guess
yeah I thought it was like about wit I
guess it's about women I don't have no
idea what it's about I don't think we're
his target demographic but he's not like
a working comedian I think he is Daniel
Tosh is his name it's a bit been used to
be into it like it's a little it's for
boys and it's before our time got it
okay well that's that on that yeah like
just like a really good story that just
went wrong you know yeah well it's a
really good story that went it was like
cute and sweet
yeah and now it yep so everyone like
also he's just a regular guy he was just
looking for some beer he wasn't trying
to be a public figure but he wasn't to
go viral
um times people put themselves in the
spotlight and yes you have to answer for
all of your sins but like he wasn't
trying to do any of that so now he's
just like this it's this weird situation
for a guy who was just trying to do some
good
yeah just don't see the point like and
the fact that the reporter himself rich
just rich yep you know and that's the
point it's like every just rich is
Robert Smith whether you're casting
judgment or whether you're being judged
for what you've done like everyone has
made mistakes and everyone has said
something that they obviously are
ashamed of and I think how you handle it
speaks volumes about you and I think he
really handled it like a champ like yeah
he will get a ton of [ __ ] honest he's
Carson king of Iowa great name yeah Lee
it's 11 of and make a wish I wish that
the Toxic cancel culture eventually
makes its way out of society and that I
you know can get enough like special
amen amen
okay did the final story a little
business so this isn't it's something
that we've really talked about I think
we talked about the fact that we work is
trying to go public okay and I think we
shat all over that just a little bit
right um but we work there's been major
drama with we work in like the biz
community recently and specifically
around their CEO why is because
everyone's just walking around giving up
their business cards causing controversy
yeah it's like there's such a
competitive like nature yeah that
there's literally going at each other's
throats yeah but today's business is it
brought to you by vistaprint the
importance of feeling professional
polished and prepared when it counts is
right now for small business owners and
people who produce their own podcasts
being plugged in and prepared when an
opportunity comes up is crucial we know
this firsthand those moments happen all
the time they're happening now and
having a business card that shows how
professionals how professional you are
in your pocket ready to hand out is the
first step in making something good
happen you can choose a style a finish
shape or paper with Vistaprint you own
the now with free shipping on any
business card in any quantity and
because you can pick colors fonts
designs and images that means you can
create something as unique and
compelling as your business you plug
your information into tons of templates
they have fresh designs and cool
styles for your type of company or you
can upload your own original layout and
you can upgrade to a unique touch like
rounded corners if you could pick the
paper stock the style the quantity and
all the details that are right for you
this supreme wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to mr. print comm and
enter promo code toast to for free
shipping on all business cards and style
and any style any quantity it's a
limited time offer so only now at
vistaprint.com
promo code toast to that is promo code
toast followed by the number to thank
you guys back to the business back to
the business we work CEO steps down as
company reportedly considers layoffs so
they are trying to go public by the end
of the year at this insane valuation
there have been all of these like
analyses of the company where it's like
it's not worth anything
what they're doing is out of control
they have no real plan and so now that
the CEO has stepped down because I think
a lot of people were finding fault with
him for the company's failures but it's
it's getting crazy because they're still
trying to go public by the end of the
year and if they don't they could
default unlike millions billions of
dollars worth of loans and that's crazy
because when you think about we work I
don't think it's the the concept that's
like what's gonna make them go public
it's the fact that they own so much real
estate what they don't I I ask someone
they own some of it and they don't know
so they're not the founder as you know
as a small company that actively looked
in a we work i cannot imagine anyone who
wants to work in a we work it is so
[ __ ] expensive and it's literally a
cubicle like we managed to we work and
we like thought we had a healthy budget
and i was it was literally gonna like it
was it was shocking it was demoralizing
that they would even six three people in
the surface that small like yes it was
shocking and this doesn't surprise me
that they're feeling like maybe make
bigger office spaces for less expensive
prices and you will have a better
business totally so um my newsletter
signed it up really well for me today
because a lot wrap your head around okay
menus letter is called me to know and
it's a good one Adam Newman has stepped
down as CEO of we were camel Serna
served as non-executive chairman of the
company he co-founded as
to save its IPO Neumann was forced out
over scrutiny of his management style
erratic behavior and weworks huge losses
the week company as its formerly known
is also said to be considering landing
off as much as a third of its staff
while it works to go public by the end
of the year if we work doesn't make that
deadline it may have to default on
billions of debt drama you know that's
that's why being a business owner in
this day and age it's not easy but
what's so crazy is that they're an
either a place where they're gonna
default on billion dollars of debt or
they're gonna go public at a forty seven
billion dollar IPO I like how can you be
both whenever I hear about companies
that like make no money have a million
people on staff like that is what being
like a tech company in in this day and
age is like never having sold a dollar
but automatically being worth over a
million dollars Oh over a billion I'm so
crazy no or selling billions of dollars
over and being worth none and not being
able to make a profit for the next ten
years I don't understand uber at all I
don't understand nuber at all like I
understand that they invest in the
future and the platforms and the
technologies but like they charge a
premium they treat their drivers like
[ __ ] so like what are you doing with all
that money yeah and like they take like
30% Commission's of all their drivers
like hard-earned money it makes no
goddamn sense it makes you no goddamn
sense but yeah we reckon this isn't a
place where they'll either be in the red
or they'll be worth 47 million dollars
on the stock market which is why what is
the stock market I just don't know how
you can be both I get you a company that
can go go that could default on all
their loans or go public at a four to
seven billion dollar evaluation yeah
that is like such a that is the perfect
like statement as to what is wrong with
the world it's a bubble like and how I
just truly don't understand it know how
I just don't understand and I really
don't understand
the stock market like I just want to say
that you know I actually did go on CNBC
when snapchat went public and to this
day I think it was one of the best days
of my life like this is so much fun like
people they're like did not know what I
was doing and like I was on this
panelists with all this people like
wearing ties and I was talking about
these DJ Khaled on snapchat it was so
funny and I told everyone I didn't think
would be a wise investment to invest in
snapchat and look at me super junior
teacher okay we are going to take a
quick
see oh yes I did watch Oh see it was
actually a great episode great it was
madness pandemonium like everyone was
just so crazy Gina
when when they were still at the
hospital and Gina was like literally
starting fights with everyone like
Brotman for calling her her younger
sister like Gina is on the brink of an
incredible mental breakdown agreed but I
felt everything Gina was saying and
personal I just want to say Bronwyn
Kelly and Emily are like the worst trio
I agree I'm like they are like
separately I like it each of them
individually sometimes together they are
the what Jackie
they are the trio like they're the trees
they're the frase from me Gus no no no
they didn't choose the trio look they
got into the trio by default which is
why it's so sad they weren't horrible
when they were sitting around and Kelly
was being like so not sensitive to shot
even if Shannon speed radix like she
went to the hospital like no one goes
out of their way to go to the hospital
I'm sorry I disagree with you no and
honestly as someone who was mildly
concussed once at my wedding like in
that moment you really don't know what
you're supposed to do but by the way in
that moment you were justified you felt
from literally like 6 feet up and you
hit your head on the floor like no but
hitting someone on the head when they
have a metal bowl on their head like
that's not no I'm sorry I totally
disagree with you I supp China and I
love Shannon like I thought she was
being so like so sure mad and dramatic
but like Kelly she just feel bad for
what you don't hit people on the head
that Kelly should've had a better
reaction like just to being like oh I'm
sorry I'm like behind her back say that
you think she's being dramatic but like
to her face she just got back to house
well I agree but Shannon was being so
out of control like so dramatic like so
stupid with the cat scan and then by the
way I totally agree with Kelly's
boyfriend like if you have a mild
concussion you're not you're merely the
less English what's nice right I agree
but a mild concussion like actually no
you can drink then that's fine I think
but I think she just wanted to make sure
there was nothing else wrong because you
never know and you don't take chances
with your head oh my god no I'm sorry
like Jaggi it was so dramatic it's
dramatic sure but like she's a mom you
don't hate chances with your head I
disagree that she left I look it was so
stupid I don't know I think it's her
prerogative to go to the hospital that's
like that's her choice to make good
she's only ruining her own good time so
when Kelly is like sitting there just
like being so mean and
girls are just backing up like Bronwyn
is the most spineless woman yeah
honestly I don't even know where
brunette shams on anything because she
never makes a definitive statement how
does she even stand up what she doesn't
know it's a great point like even the
conversation she had with Gina when they
went on the hike like it's so empty like
nothing she is but I don't know whose
side she's on I know she's staying with
the phrase for fajitas but I don't even
know because I think a part of her wants
to survive on the show and she knows
that in order to do that you have to be
friends with Tamra challenge you and say
anything yeah if you get people to like
her and like she stands for nothing she
stands by nothing and I think where we
disagree the most she doesn't stand at
all right she sits by nothing I think
where we disagree on the most is Gina
versus Emily okay let's go
because there's something so losery
about Gina I mean actually everything
about Gina is so losery to me and I
don't you think Emily is cool no I think
that Emily's genuine like I think emily
has a real friendship with Gina and
while I do think that Emily could be
there more for Gina like Gina has got to
take some [ __ ] responsibility
for what's going on in her life like her
blaming Emily from the fact like all
this cheetahs happening to her Emily's
not there like you have bigger [ __ ]
fish to fry
you almost got arrested in front of
their kids like stop focusing so much on
the fact that Emily wasn't there for you
and didn't say the right thing and
wanted you to come to Vegas and I did
think and as much as I thought what
Emily did was incredibly weird and David
what Gina that was me that was me for
sure but they were having an honest
conversation and going below the belt so
Gina just said what we were all thinking
I think Emily and in that conversation
like when they were both in the room
like that was a conversation to like
mend gina finally told her why she was
upset and and we just didn't know how to
be a friend like no it's like she can't
go below the surface and i think at the
end of the day it's because she like
puts a like a nice coat on everything
and doesn't want to talk about what's
going on in her life and doesn't want to
like see reality so she just like his
surface level and i think she's a
surface level friend even though they
have a deeper connection right now with
when she was like and that's it and even
if Gina had said more things that she
didn't know what to say in order to be a
friend because she's just like living a
fake life right now I don't know I just
really what Gina's just like any
and yeah her life is a hot [ __ ] mess
and she's just trying to get through and
she's not doing the right things all the
time but Emily really can't relate to
her because Emily's in the same position
and she's just pretending like
everything's okay well but that's
Emily's prerogative to do so I just
think that like when she came into the
room and she was like just tell me what
I did like so I can apologize we can
move forward like I just I thought that
the way that Gina handled like okay
let's be real like Emily didn't really
do anything to Gina that was that
terrible but she's miffed she's missed
so I just thought like the way Gina
handle that was so immature like an
actual two-year-old and we know Gina is
a two-year-old actually when they went
into the room I was already I'm teen
Gina because when Kelly was being so
[ __ ] mean to gina saying she's not an
accomplishment great hit her on the head
talking so much trash to her and g.8
Emily I can't Emily I can't separate
them and emily is sitting right there
and doesn't stand up for her friend once
and you say we're best friends we do
everything together we sleep together we
travel together we talk every day and
you don't have your friends back when
they already went into that room I was
like you're a shitty friend by the way I
agree but in that Gina was like [ __ ]
ignoring and Malaysia and answer any of
her calls or text messages she knew that
Gina was mad at her and then Gina is
like out like with the trace of mica
it's like honestly I agree [ __ ] you you
know she's a real if your real friends
and like yeah you get into these
situations where you're miffed at
someone if I'm mad at you but someone's
coming for you or I know you're mad at
me like oh that goes away for a second
like I have your back we can fight later
about it if you're sure if they're the
true friends that Emily keeps saying
that they are which I do think that they
are yeah but I just think that like Gina
is so immature and such a child
and like really is making such poor life
choices and is putting a lot of the
blame on other people it's like
frustrating to watch her be in such a
downward spiral and I just think Emily's
a really good friend for her to have
like Emily has her [ __ ] together as much
as she might not be like expressing all
of her feelings like she is a lawyer
like she has her life together and I
think Gina could really use a friend
like that and I think Tamra and Shannon
are like in this different stage of
their lives where like their kids are
grown and like I just don't know if her
being with a tamarind Shannon like
groupie is the right move for her right
that I understand why she's doing
Tamra and Shannon have both had the rug
pulled out from under them they both
have been in the exact position that
Gina is in where it's just like you
cannot see the far through the trees
your life is a hot [ __ ] mess Emily
doesn't understand what it's like to be
in that situation
according to things I've read like she
might know soon um and so she just can't
like Shannon and Tamara can give her
good advice her the very least say like
it's horrible right now but it will get
better like and Emily's just not saying
anything about anything and just
wondering why she's not in Vegas and
then being like I hate when people do
that where it's like I'm sorry that I
just wanted you there yeah like no but
there's just something about Jeana I
cannot get behind like agree she's my
favorite she's literally the worst like
everything that comes out of her mouth I
just want to like cry and just I just I
really don't like her but also I was
really struggling watching the last
night's episode because my heart is
always with Kelly Dodd but like she's
more often than not like indefensible
she was so wrong last night a million
different ways I loved her I know I
loved her too but she was wrong
and then she was someone watch what
happens live and she was being heard
she's being nut she was being even more
wrong um Megan McCain was on and she was
very articulate but I wasn't agreeing
with some of her Housewives positions
and and but me because Kelly was sitting
right there you can't disagree with
Kelly it's actually very hard to be on
watch repens I was like a super fan with
a person from the franchise I find that
it always muddies the water yeah so I
think like Kelly was just wrong in every
in every respect and the hitting people
it's like this isn't kindergarten oh I
agree they're not now let me add that
she hit someone again is the stupidest
most insane part of the whole episode
right and if I were cheatin like I
flipped when Gina flipped like that
would just have brought me to the brink
like these petty tres have previa for me
Gus
like no it's true and I'm so loser a
like I can't it's so easy
okay we're gonna talk to Stephanie home
a because she's also gonna be on watch
happen side with any Dorfman tonight and
I just want to ask her like if they know
each other and things like that so stay
tuned take a break go to the bathroom
get a snack we're gonna be back with
Stephanie a woman in just a few minutes
you have a question for her feel free to
leave it on our Instagram page or on the
YouTube feed and we will do our absolute
best to get it to her we love you guys
be right back bye
you
we are back with the queen of Real
Housewives of Dallas Stephanie home and
we are so excited to have we talked
about you all the time like we love you
so much
we think you are just like one of the
best housewives and we are greatest of
all time you're on our all-star team
100% sweetie had a new episode of Dallas
coming tonight right yes and you're
gonna be on watch happens live tonight
with Andi Dorfman I am I'm excited I've
never met her before he's my friend
Devon
I'd watch all the bachelors do all the
bachelor in paradise I am at the biggest
nerd yes she's so cool and so funny and
you should get a drink with her
afterward she's really okay I definitely
would yeah definitely do you like going
on like chubbins I've you know I do but
this is the first time I've ever gone on
without somebody from my cast I found
out like Brandi I've gone on with Carrie
but I've never gone on with someone
other than a cast member that is so
interested in I think they think I'm too
nervous I don't think it's a compliment
so baby you're gonna prove yourself
tonight I'm gonna prove myself I'm gonna
go there and yeah not be nervous and
we're in such an interesting place in
Real Housewives of Dallas because we
lost Carrie but then we got Carrie yeah
um and I to really like knew Carrie I do
miss old Carrie I like I'd like to have
Carrie - um but you have been over the
last like two seasons super open about a
lot of the stuff that you went through
and I just we watch laughs last week's
episode last night and you see a lot of
the timely and kind of talking about
similar things she went through but
almost kind of as a defense mechanism
and they always cut to you when she does
that and I want to know if you find that
in a wank when I okay so whenever a
watched last week's episode even this
week's and I do it makes me sad I don't
want there to be a like almost like her
versus me I feel like yeah it's
different feel bad because I don't want
to make her look bad because I'm dealing
with some things so I don't know so it's
sometimes it does it makes me feel
guilty
yeah very guilty even though I don't cut
the show I do feel guilty yes do I think
that she says
things at inappropriate times yes I do
um however she's been through a lot and
I feel like I should i I hope that
people honor her journey much as you do
mine and sometimes I feel like the
audience gives me a lot of praise and
not so much her yeah and I know her
delivery is different yeah but I can't
imagine having her childhood and coming
out the other side so yeah if that makes
any sense it does but did you think she
was being too negative in grace um you
know her sharing her story
doesn't bother me as much as her
throwing suicide out there the way she
did it just felt very jarring it felt
like it was random I just like that
something you don't talk about like the
way that she did and I hope she watches
it and can see where I'm coming from who
but it's I mean people kill themselves
like every 60 seconds and I think that
that is something that's a very serious
topic and not something to throw out at
a dinner unless you truly are dealing
with those feelings and then there's a
conversation that needs to be had you
know that supports her yeah yeah it was
it was an interesting conversation it
was a weird moment I think it was a long
day yeah and the lung trauma it had that
toilet yeah condemned toilet did you pee
in it I did you know I had to go it was
we were in that car for three hours
I was thinking refer to like just pee in
a bush I you know I would have and and
maybe this episode I do I am NOT I have
no shame I'm from Oklahoma and I peed in
many bishops did Cameron pee in the bus
I'm you pee in the toilet
she did she doing yeah it's funny yeah
there's no way there's no way a dress is
too long mystical e oh yeah like I think
every one of us did that is so so you're
one of us said that you have to go I
mean when you have to go you have to go
[ __ ] and the bridge that Leah and
Carrie were fighting about you guys
eventually go on the bridge did you walk
you know and if you have to watch and
see I guess I don't get in see how much
that it did look a little Jer
you guys have kids no I mean there's no
way whenever I saw it I didn't want to
be a fun heater but there's no way I
wanted to walk across that thing but
don't you understand I totally got with
Carrie was saying it's like you're
opening your house to everyone like
Leeanne like stop it's so annoying when
someone's name yes but she had something
that's so personal to you like it's her
family's house I definitely understood
where she was coming from in that sense
but I did think it was a little weird
that like she was like forcing LeAnn to
sleep with her like their new friends
yeah Yeah right not supposed to be used
for production or you know there were I
think seven rooms and only six of us so
we definitely each could have had her
own room especially one room of tes
exactly all right you know I had my own
bed because I was sharing room with
Cameron so I did have my own bed which
is different so I do get it's different
LeAnn not wanting to like spoon carry I
know her delivery has wrong but I
totally understand her not wanting to
like sleep in the same bed as someone
she literally just met yeah no I mean
again I get it even you know with
Cameron I mean we're not the closest so
even that was a little awkward awkward
sharing space with somebody that you're
not like really close with yeah did you
get closer because of it or was it just
awkward across really properties I feel
like she's with it you gotta get clean
what done the scene very organized just
like it I was just like I'm gonna make
sure I'm just a good roommate like I
didn't want to be like Deandra
Yeah right which bothered like to have
that reputation is the absolute worst oh
and she laughs about it like people make
fun of her and she just goes so that she
has such a thick skin I've seen in her
roast that she initiated which wasn't
really a bro so it was like more like a
bar-mitzvah it wasn't a roast but that
reminds me of the incredibly awkward
um conversation that she had with your
husband yes so and I thought Travis was
really and I said Travis is serious like
I suck like he honestly like he's scares
me that honestly I had a meeting with
him I would show up like if even if I
was me like I know
obviously I prefer to go so like I can't
believe that she didn't show up at first
like that is to me like bad business 101
you know and yes I don't like she should
have messaged me at 1:30 a.m. grateful a
meeting with him yeah and I know that
some people are you know like they don't
want any message I'm like message my
husband I do not care like yeah I would
rather not be in the middle yeah and
that in the morning I did not I mean it
was 1:30 a.m. I saw the message on my
way home from taking my kids to school
cuz I more day my children bathed and
fed and out the doors so that way
they're not again late for school
and but yeah I feel like he was so
annoyed and he and I are very different
he that he will call somebody out
that's so funny and that's so relatable
like I if someone I cannot confront
anyone like I would literally rather
died like step all over me I'm good yeah
no I feel like I appreciate that about
him cuz I'm not like that but whenever I
watch the episode I was like honestly I
laughed but I was also like oh my god
poor Deandra
so well and he forgave her and he's
gonna meet with her crack don't see that
you will see that too and he said the
most astute thing on the phone like he
just he breezed by it but it was like
the way I choose to live my life he's
like some apologizes I'm good like you
know what in this day and age I forget
especially in housewife franchises like
you apologizing time after time like you
worth you apologize it's over like that
is a great way to live your life yeah
you know absolutely absolutely I
appreciated that I create hey he's
actually better about that than I am
because I'll kind of hold on to things
I'll be like you apologize wait
literally well like move on I mean I
wish I was more like that I guess
also I think sometimes guys are better
at that too than girls yeah maybe not
maybe shaking things at face value I'm
not reading into it like guys kind of
let each other have it and they move on
with their lives and I think girls
sometimes you stew in it yeah I accept
your apology but not really yeah
your house is beautiful yeah you got rid
of the pool yes do you ever miss it no
necessary that
one day I wake up and I'm like me I wish
I could go for this is so beautiful
Jackie and I went to Highland Park
Village we went shopping and we like
really felt like you and Brad dude like
I was we had such a great day it is such
a great place to live beautiful have you
I really just so incredible you could
have like messaged us we should be back
we have friends we have big plans and so
we're really seeing all the friendships
like starts develop it is it hard to
throw someone new in the mix because for
the most part all the girls are ot's
right except we didn't OD Andrea Andrea
tangerine Cameron and Brandi Lana and I
are and the three from the original
season a hat and you know getting I do I
said getting rid of Carrie but not
having Carrie duper back in and having
Carrie Brittingham come in if the
dynamic change is so much that it's it
was hard for me to get my footing
because it just felt off and yeah that's
some of the reason that in the beginning
of the season I felt it just didn't feel
like everything felt off to me yeah um
but then whenever you get in a groove
and you get to know like Carrie and she
becomes part of the group I think that
audience and everyone will really start
to warm up she's fantastic and you'll
see Carrie Jubran as well but I like
even watching this know there are times
when I do miss Carrie I think Carrie
Carrie brought like a lot I miss her
interviews she's so funny
yes she's has such a dry sense of humor
so they're even watching it and I'm like
oh I miss I do miss her yeah she's a
really good friend it's nice to see that
I think that's why you're on track to be
like our greatest housewife of all time
because I could cross the board like
personal like you're interesting you
open up like you're such a good friend
to all of your friends but you also are
interesting and like I just love
watching you you know and it's hard to
be all of those things to be a good
friend would also be like in the drama
but not to in it and likes you know you
just being on the right side of history
thank you but it is about how you handle
it
what you did like No yes it's you know
this year um I kind of stood up for
myself maybe a little bit more like if I
think there was a certain thing that I
was just like I turn to father I mean I
started resenting this certain person
and what you will see and actually spoke
my mind which I never do because like
you said I would rather teach nice
mm-hmm and I've been a lot of times at
my own sacrifice my own sacrifice
because I would feel like crap inside
and apologize for things I wasn't even
sorry for right so they felt good about
the situation yeah and I don't I don't
know I just felt like that's just not
being true to myself that's being true
to somebody else it's not a good way to
live either yeah it wasn't it was just
it was very soul sucking so and so those
things I'm excited to see yes and
nervous to see because whenever you go
out of your comfort zone there is growth
but there's also a lot of scary things
happen yeah yeah I want to take
questions from Instagram because we got
so many and certain questions for you
and one of them is such a good question
I can't believe anything of it myself
from Lindsey Joe what is your favorite
fast-food chain in Dallas do you love
Whataburger because we are obsessed with
Whataburger like it is the best fast
food chain in all America
okay so throughout college I always went
to water burger like at 2:00 a.m. and
still water it was the best best best
food ever and so I am very much a girl
of convenient so Taco Bell I feel like I
go through a lot with my husband cuz
it's right by our house and I still have
water burger there's just not a closed
water burger to me there's not as many
as there should be
yeah we had a hard time finding one in
Dallas it took us like days until we ran
into one yeah very upsetting yeah it's
really like Dallas a hard place to find
a water burger but chick-fil-a Taco Bell
are my two good ones do you get free
classes at soul cycle because of Holmen
lockers yes you know what I love soul
cycle and I have a lot of free it's
cycling classes yes they do you get them
since good I love souls I go I had :
maybe she's like no and I never forget
I'm like thank you for these Oh keeping
my things secure oh my gosh I love you
I'm out there and they I mean it's such
a great like like SoulCycle equinox that
whole game that everything they do is
just so amazing and elevated and yeah
this is a question from someone who I
believe is your assistant okay
Trey yes is it the farc question what is
it I mean you know I don't feel like
it's healthy for you just hold it in oh
my gosh
and probably you know not too long after
I started I don't know how he fell to
the hills like probably it's like three
weeks and I think it was like an event
so long as he felled in the fire yeah
that was like three weeks like I went to
go outside via lady and I li I think I'm
as drunk one day and it just
accidentally thank you this is from
Lauryn Ward what's one of your what's
one way your life has forever changed
since being a housewife besides from the
obvious being recognized and working
with brands and if you go back in time
and tell yourself one thing before the
show what would it be okay if I went
back in time and told myself something
before I started season one cuz season
one and season two I was as like a
terrified I don't know how I even they
asked me back every year I was like what
are you sure but I would say just be
honestly be yourself it took me a few
years to realize that you don't have to
be perfect and and that people relate to
the cracks more than they relate to this
facade that you have up and that's what
I would tell myself and then something
that's changed I just think I'm more
open and authentic about myself and who
I am and I don't expect as much from
myself like I don't expect myself to to
be perfect and if I make mistake I give
myself a break and I used to not be like
that
so it's something that's very refreshing
yeah that's actually great advice I'm
free like read Becca baby do you want to
have a little girl so that Brewin and
her
married so you know Mama's 40 if my
husband could get pregnant and carry the
child and have the baby
yes but it's only mother metal to me
that happen I don't feel like I just
think I my kids are 8 and 10 I'm gonna
age at a stage now in my life where it's
pretty easy and I can't defend that yeah
so I don't think so unless something
happens right justice also is has a
vasectomy he's been neutered so it would
be they are reversible yeah I'd have to
go Reapers that oh yeah this is such a
good question from Barth boehner can us
Stephanie what she thinks about LeAnn
going around town asking for free
wedding services oh my gosh do you know
all that's a question I'm scared I might
get on tonight you know watching it it
was very awkward
I just it was so uncomfortable it was
uncomfortable I just hope that that was
something that was almost planned out
like where they knew that was happening
yeah and the lady wasn't put on the spot
yeah you do like somebody asked me that
their day on Twitter they're like do you
ever get free stuff doing the show yeah
absolutely you do and I've had people
offer to give me flowers for parties I
think just so they have some recognition
and so that does happen so and I think a
lot of us have used you know other
people's services and they offer so I
don't wanna say that's never I just
wouldn't I've never put it out there and
I never liked it so it was yeah like it
would just it was awkward but I'm hoping
that it was awkward on purpose yeah I
have not even asked Leon about that I
didn't know it was really hot yeah and
you know what I haven't really I should
reach out to her I didn't really call
her after the last episode either cuz I
did feel like it was awkward because I
did feel like they kind of put the
stories against it we're heading to you
when she was talking and and I don't and
but I did feel bad about that so yeah
guilty to even reach out and you it's a
hard episode for her I just freaked out
that's what a friend should do if yeah
like she was just in a bad place that
day she was she was in a really bad
place I feel like for that trip yeah
okay
but you know if you look back and I've
talked to her about this I feel like her
hardest moments are always on cast
like that's when she always Cyril Miller
to boat yeah like end of the house with
the glass yeah yeah yeah oh no sorry ash
I was in bed with brandy I'm so scared
and I never experienced and my password
like they were yelling at each other and
I was like excess itching carried over
of like recording on your phone so
ridiculous that was so crazy looking
back now I'm you're used to date is I
have never that was the first time I'd I
was like oh my gosh we are all good yeah
this is from Kat kassover can you tell
us the story of how you and brandy met
and became friends so Brandy was one of
the first people I met when I met
started dating Travis we went to dinner
Travis night with her and Bryan Bryan
and Travis are best friends but so thank
you and I remember sitting at dinner and
we were so annoying and I was like I
fell in love with Brandi way before
Travis it was just intimate like her
instant connection and yeah it was so
easy
dear do your husband's like love that
you're so close they yeah I mean it's
easy to travel together
yeah but they also think we're really
annoying and so you'll see like later on
the season we do a double date and
totally Brandi and Stephanie style
you'll love it so funny and you have a
podcast now - yeah it's called week we
des a PS do you get in trouble from
Bravo from some of the stuff you guys
talk about so have you ever you know
it's hard to talk about the show like
you really just can't give away spoilers
scenes or you know certain you know
spoilers so kind of the same way that
you would to press you just have to
tease um but also I wanted it to be a
place where we're not being negative
about the women on the show because I
don't think that's fair to them for us
to create a space for ourselves to have
fun and then just trash our cast members
and so it's been fun it's just something
that's fun light-hearted we've always
wanted to spin off and we have not
gotten one yet
you can spin off like
spinoff you wish to see it yeah exactly
so funny do your guys's kids get along
really well they are such good friends
so chance and Brooklyns Haku every day
they FaceTime each other they play
roblox together this like a little
online game and it's so cute like he'll
I guess in that game you can buy people
each other gifts
it's just she'll buy him a car he'll buy
her a house it's really cute
mm and then Brooklyn and Brooklyn and
crews are kind of you know the two
younger so they're not as close but
chance and Brooklyn the oldest are great
friends and you boys like filming you
know um you don't see my kids on it
probably as as much as others because
whenever I whenever I do film I and they
come home from school I give them the
option yeah would you like to do this
would you not if they have a really bad
day at school and they come home and
they're in a mood I'm not gonna force
them to do something that I know is just
self sabotaging like I'm not gonna set
them up for failure mother and but a lot
of times they are excited about it they
love doing like the painting your dog
with Cameron they still talk about that
that was so much fun so so cute so they
will film but I really let that be their
destroys because they're eight and ten
and I don't want them to resent me
either yeah yeah or the show yeah um I
have one last question for you and it's
one that we've been talking about for a
while and something that started to
happen last season which I find to be so
weird and I think that the friendship
between Cameron and LeAnn is one that is
so strange and I don't understand like
the benefit like they're just two
totally different people and Cameron is
so defensive of LeAnn and it's just this
weird friendship that makes no sense to
me but I'm not in it so maybe it makes
more sense to you and like Cameron's
yeah cam has been so hard on like Brandi
for being inappropriate when like LeAnn
is delusive laureate and she endorses
her behavior and it doesn't make sense
but I feel like in some of the previews
we've seen like does that start to
crumble a little bit you will see there
there is a shift over point in the
season but but that always was something
that bothered me as I felt I always
liked Cameron and I have and I do love
her if you're watching this Cameron I do
not not like you and
I do feel like we fight over such petty
things but then something big will
happen and it's kind of looked over and
Leanne and that has always kind of
bothered me I took different sad she's
very critical yes yeah so I'm like I
don't mind if you're critical just be
like that with everybody
yeah and then you don't feel so picked
on I totally feel there it's a very
weird friendship and I don't understand
like what they both get out of it it's
like they buried about it within the
woods together and yeah like Leanne
buried a body for Cameron cos he and yes
but you know I think there are some
friendships where loyalty means
friendship but loyalty to a fault yeah
and and I feel like there was a point
where brandy and I had very much blind
loyalty to each other and that's not
always healthy and it's not and I feel
like it's not healthy for ourselves it's
not it also makes horrible TV because
people are like you're lunatic
yeah for agreeing with everything this
person says and vice-versa so for me I
think it's a healthier way to be a few I
think it's also being a better friend if
you tell somebody and I don't agree with
you okay
hoping the growth yeah absolutely um
well we love you we can't meet want you
tonight I'm watching up and sliding a
new episode of Dallas premieres on Bravo
at nine o'clock right yes pack and
follow Stephanie home and on instagram
at Steph Holman and go to SoulCycle and
get a home and Locker we love you thank
you guys for listening to the morning
toast millennium Morning Show we go I
have Monday to Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so feel free to
subscribe and like this video we're also
available on the podcast or on Spotify
iTunes anywhere you listen to podcast
subscribe great you know to do we will
see you tomorrow with Abigail Baker from
Blue Bloods bye
you